interesting phenomenon has been uh
occurring lately I'll give an example
just a couple days ago uh I was in the
supermarket and I was picking up a few
things and I Come Around the aisle and
as I'm coming around the aisle I
practically collide
with this young woman who's we just have
baskets you know I didn't have that much
to get I want to say I had like five
items okay and I'm gonna say she had
like four she had a basket but we kind
of collided almost with each other and I
said excuse me and she looked up and she
had little earbuds in her ears
and she took an earbud out and she said
I'm listening to your podcast right now
which freaked me out a little bit yeah
I'm interrupting myself and I sent out a
tweet about this but I realized it's
been happening more frequently walking
around I'll bump into someone and
they'll say it actually happened near
our podcast Studio here in Larchmont
Center and said oh I'm listening to you
right now huh and it feels like we need
to discuss this meaning what should the
etiquette be do I need to reward these
people somehow you know what I mean do I
need to have a Willy Wonka golden ticket
on me at all times if you're listening
to the podcast and you can prove it as
you pass me
um is there a secret handshake I mean
that's all I'm just opening this up and
it may be that we decide no there's
nothing we do I have no obligation to
these people but it's a it's a
phenomenon that has not existed
before you know you couldn't no one
could run into me uh while they were
watching my late night show all those
years because they were in their home
watching it yeah so this is a new thing
where people are walking around roaming
around possibly listening to me and as
we know I'm not I'm not some you know
one of those celebs that is always
hidden from public view I do everything
I can to be seen constantly you do
that's another thing they might see you
put the podcast on and be like oh my God
I'm listening to you right now whatever
pumps my ego pumps my ego I don't care
at all okay with that I'm okay with them
cheating
I'm wondering are there people who are
listening to the podcast and see me and
go oh God and go the other way does that
happen oh interesting yeah
I can't take a double dose of this guy's
voice right now I doubt that uh I bet
they'd be more embarrassed to say oh I'm
actually listening to you right now and
they'll seem obsessed with you which you
would love love I would love that yeah
yeah I get really weird when people say
they recognize my voice to the point
where I feel like because you are also a
people pleaser so I don't know if I need
to give them something and sometimes I'm
like do I do I give them numbers I love
that you're my personal assistant and
you're
thinking about giving people my personal
phone number they call you like you know
what you should do is hand them your
phone and say you get to pick one
celebrity phone number out of there yeah
and guess what I would not be the pick
of the of the of the numbers that you
probably have but it's exciting
technology has created a new situation
where someone can be hearing your voice
walking around in the world and then
encounter you and so if that happens it
feels like I
I don't know I'm just questioning you
should give every person that's
listening to you and finds you in public
a hundred dollars and then this make
this kind of like a a treasure hunt you
know I guess [ __ ] you
is the appropriate response I'm sorry
500 now you're talking no uh no I do not
want to do that you know right now what
happens when people see me and they want
to show that they know and this happens
all the time is they say katakai yeah
and that happens I walk through airports
and I hear katakai katakai I'm even
starting to get some of those now too
yeah it's it's getting pandemicy yeah
well you do wear a hat that says I'm
Matt Gourley kind of Conor O'Brien
um and it's not a little baseball cap
it's a very large top hat that the Mad
Hatter would have worn in uh Alice in
Wonderland but anyway that's your
business
um I don't know I don't know what the
answer is I mean I just didn't know if
there's a little I'm very appreciative
that people listen isn't the gift the
podcast like you're welcome
you're welcome right
people say hey I'm listening to you
right now you should just be like be
like welcome yeah with real attitude
yeah [ __ ] you you're welcome yeah maybe
that's yours I love that [ __ ] you you're
welcome yeah hey uh Conan I'm just
encountering you right now at this
Buddhist temple you're lighting a candle
and I also happen to be listening to
[ __ ] you
you're welcome
oh boy I saw it on the podcast you're
talking about how kindness is important
yeah well that's the podcast
you're lucky to get it it's pretty hard
to get it's actually free and available
wherever you get your podcast
yeah that's what I'm gonna do this would
be like you're welcome for your for that
gift I gave you yeah you know I don't
know so you went one way girly went to I
hand them a crisp hundred dollar bill
Chris
mint issue very different you know what
I should have gag hundred dollar bills
made it looks like a hundred dollar bill
but really it's my face on it yeah and
it says have been Conan and I'm making
like a really lascivious face on it and
I've got moose antlers and you know same
as saying [ __ ] you yeah well that's on
the other side we're usually there's the
the pyramid with the eye that's where
this is the [ __ ] you
gotta you know you gotta lay these
things out yeah anyway we haven't
figured it out yet but uh if you do see
me and you are listening to the podcast
when you see me when you see Conan just
go up to him and go [ __ ] you no don't
don't do that but what if I'm with my
kids that's going to be traumatic for me
thanks a lot Matt you're a good guy
you're welcome my daughter will be
crying why did that happen no I was like
probably laugh oh yeah they love it when
I'm verbally assaulted on the street
into a session we did it again yep all
right well I'll see you out there keep
on listening fans
[ __ ] you you're welcome